why are we outside whatever oh okay well  there's bad oh I don't like this not  that bad come on don't be such a baby  about it  hello sneaky sneaky sneaky oh do  somebody didn't wipe probably cross-eyed  right all right anyway so yeah okay what  the hell oh I see a skipper scamper out  there oh you wanna play a game of  peekaboo won't know where to play point  two point two point one point point  no okay oh what a lovely mysterious  white substance you have in your ball  whoa Oh dark Oh hmm well I'm not a  hundred percent sure but I think the  secret is right here oh okay well whoa  whoa whoa whoa whoa what the hell was  that  why boobs hell yeah oh hell yeah I've  got boobs oh yeah oh look at me let er  I've got incredible pectoral muscles but  I think I got boobs  hey yes go in there  oh hey how's it going there whoa  [Music]  you  [Music]